I think the appeal of lease number is  that the shops are unique there's  something for everybody  you've got the department stores but  you've also got the little boutique  places and then you've got a great cafe  culture that goes alongside it so you  can spend all day shopping have lunch  and go out in the evening as well if you  want to offer something for everybody  people don't realize that you've got all  these activities on the doorstep of  Mission other you can do kayaking  sailing you can go biking you can go  walking you can get running and it's all  within a central area  you  there's a great sense of community in  this town and one of the things you hear  over and over again is how friendly  people are there are all sorts of open  spaces and play areas and events that  happen throughout the year that really  draw people together